Tên phòng thống kê của ra mong gầu cho biết được rất cực nổ được người dân để phương gọi là giúp
đã khiến hơn 20,8 chăm con ra xúc chết.
Chỉ tính xe trong thống một năm hành in không tra mình xấu,
chùi yếu tại các tình phía tay oaves, bayi ăn uke, giật khăn và tình miệng chung ốc uke khăn gái.
Thật các quan này, những mấy mô trong số 20 tình của mong gầu đang chua anh hường của hẹt tưởng thời tiết khăn nghiệp.
Giô là thần nữa dùng để chỉ mô đông cực lạnh khi mà đã bị đáng băng họng bị tất phủ rai,
khiến ra xúc không thể tình kiểm thức ăn và giải bị chiến tháng rạt.
Tình chẳng này thường xuyên kê tỉ thải lớn cho hành tranh nhoai của của ra chung á.
Trân nhoai là chủ cột kinh tề quan trọng của mong gầu với khoảng 1,5 xam dân số xúc 1,
phù thu trực tế vào đàn ra xúc để xinh kế theo số lựa chính thức.
Tổng đàn ra xúc cũng nước này đã khoảng 5,5 chụi con,
vào cuối nâng hình không tra mâm,
giới chung mong gầu đình theo dõi 3 xong dị bình thử tiết.
Đồng thời trên khai các biển pháp hỗ trợ nhằm 3 thử tiết thải chung ở trên nhoai,
trong điều kiện thử tiết mô đồng khăn nghiệt còn tiếp tục kéo sàng.